[Music]
now as you may have heard the house
ethics committee has launched an
investigation into florida congressman
matt gates for alleged
sex trafficking it's still early in the
investigation
but some details have come out yeah you
can thank me later
oh gross there's a fly in the studio not
just any fly
i was the fly on the wall of matt gates
office last week
and i heard everything
okay but what are you doing oh
sorry i have taste receptors in my feet
and i'm pretty sure somebody wiped a
sneeze right here
oh yeah yeah they definitely did you are
disgusting
oh i'm disgusting well that is nothing
compared to the stuff i heard in matt
gates office last week
like what apparently gates is under a
federal investigation for trafficking a
17 year old
across state lines oh my god that is
disgusting
i know and it's just the tip of the
iceberg
i heard he's also best friends with an
alleged child
sex trafficker who's been using venmo to
pay for sex
what a gross dumb idiot i know
what's wrong i'm sorry i just really
gotta go
oh can't you hold it till we're done i
wish i could but i defecate 300 times a
day which means every four minutes i
have to crap where else i die
dear lord every fly does that yeah
and i live in a white castle dumpster so
it's usually like 600 times a day
oh please stop give me a break i was
born in a dead possum
you are so gross oh i'm gross
because that's nothing compared to some
of the gross [ __ ] i heard
at gates office okay what did you hear
i heard the gates showed nude images of
women he claimed he slept with
to other officials while literally
standing on the floor of congress
ew i know plus
when he worked in the florida
legislature i heard he devised a game
where people got
points for sleeping with aids lobbyists
legislatures
and even interns oh that is disgusting
no wait don't drink that why i landed on
it earlier and i
might be carrying cholera seriously
no i'm definitely carrying cholera
and typhoid and dysentery you are
hideous and i would like you to leave
but but i didn't even get the most
nauseating part yet fine what's the most
nauseating part
the most nauseating part is that in the
middle of all of this
matt gates started a fundraising
campaign based entirely on the
allegations against him
and it's making tons of money
wait people are actually donating to him
because he's an accused
child sex trafficker yes
okay you're right that is the most
nauseating part
but listen you reek and i still need you
to leave
that's fine if i stay one minute longer
my bowels will erupt and i'll explode
all over the studio
get out of here
not yet not yet i hate to see him go
but i love to watch him leave you're
[Music]
gross
you